SPEAKER 1: Hello.
This video shows the Coursera
setup steps, including
your account on Coursera,
steps to enroll students,
and how to monitor
students' learning progress.
To access the Admin
console, sign into Coursera
with your credentials.
Coursera provides
several dashboards
at different stages
of the program
to track the
progress of students.
The Admin dashboard and
the Program Admin pages
show the data for your members,
learners, and completers.
This sample data shows you
how students are progressing
through your learning programs.
A student's status may be
active, inactive, or at risk.
In the Invitations
tab, you can track
and see the status
of the invitations
that you've sent
to the students.
You can also resend
invitations, if needed.
To add and invite
individual students,
complete the following steps.
Open the Coursera program for
the Associate Cloud Engineer
track, click on the
Invitations icon,
enter the individual's full
name and email address,
and click Send Invitation.
The Import Members feature
enables you to add and invite
multiple students at a time.
To import members, start by
creating an invitee list.
Create a spreadsheet with
column names exactly as shown--
full name, email, external ID.
The values in the external
ID may be left blank.
Download the student
data as a CSV file.
Here are the steps to import
students using your CSV invitee
list.
From the Invitation tab,
click Import Members.
Follow the instructions
in the Coursera dialog.
When you complete the
Import Members step,
the students receive an
automatic invitation email
from Coursera.
Your students are
now ready to start
learning on Coursera by opening
the Google Cloud Edu invitation
email with the
subject line, "You're
invited to learn on Coursera."
In the email, students
may click Join Program
to join the Associate
Cloud Engineer track.
The student can then enroll in
the first course, Google Cloud
Platform Fundamentals--
Core Infrastructure.
We have reviewed steps
for your account setup
in Coursera, student
invitations, and learning
progress monitoring.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: Hello, and welcome.
I wanted to preview the
interactive hands-on labs
platform called Qwiklabs
and how you'll actually
be practicing a
lot of the things
that you're going to learn here
inside of real Google Cloud
Platform accounts.
But you don't need
your own credentials.
Those are actually going
to be provided for you.
So let's take a look at how
the labs platform is set up.
On the right hand side
is your Instructions pane
for the actual lab.
Now, this lab's a meta lab.
It's all about
Qwiklabs in general,
but whatever your
course is, this
is where the instructions
for completing the lab
are going to take place.
So you always want to
keep this prompt open.
Now once you actually
click Start Lab,
a provisioned instance of
the Google Cloud Platform,
complete with any
additional instances,
or say you're working with
VMs, if there is something
that the lab provider
wanted you to have,
it's actually going
to be created inside
of this lab instance for
you, which is a great sandbox
instance.
Now, once, you notice,
I click Start Lab,
I have 15 minutes to
complete this lab.
I promise you that
the timers are
going to be associated with
additional padding for the labs
that you're going to do.
This isn't going to
[INAUDIBLE] take us 15 minutes.
This'll take us maybe
about five minutes.
Now, as I mentioned before, you
have the username and password
and a project ID.
What I'll ask you to do now is
click on Open Google Console.
And once you've
opened Google Console,
you'll be asked to sign
in with your email.
Now the key thing
here is if you've
used Google Resources
before, immediately, you'll
start typing in
your personal email.
I do it all the time.
Make sure you go back
to your lab credentials
screen, and copy and
paste the username that's
auto-generated for you.
This is going to
be unique for you,
and it's actually going
to be unique for every lab
that you run.
So you're going to be
creating a new student account
for each lab that you run.
Copy and paste that password.
It's going to be
different from, mine so
don't worry about
copying that down.
Click Next in your browser.
Paste in that password.
Accept the terms.
Don't worry about setting
up a secondary phone number.
Accept the terms of the
Google Cloud Platform,
and once you see a screen
that looks like this,
then you're good to go.
Make sure a key tidbit is
this is your project selector.
It should be this auto-generated
Qwiklabs alphanumeric.
If you should happen
to see something
that says either,
select a project,
or if you see something that
says, Qwiklabs Resources,
you actually want
to click on this
and make sure to select your
alphanumeric Qwiklabs ID.
And then go ahead and hit Open.
Once you're within
here, you're good to go.
So follow the instructions
for the rest of the lab.
It's going to guide you through
what products and services
that you're going
to be working with.
You can access the manual
products and services
in the upper left
hand corner here,
or if it's a lab that's
working on Cloud Shell,
all the way up here is the
button to activate Cloud Shell,
which will bring open that
terminal instance for Google
Cloud Platform.
Last few things--
back here, you'll
see that our timer is
automatically running still.
Once you're completed with
the lab, you're done with it,
now make sure in order to get
your completion stats properly
recorded, click on End Lab.
You'll be faced with a prompt
that says, are you all done?
Once you click End Lab,
your project, any data sets,
anything that
you've been working
with inside of this sandbox
project is going to be deleted.
So make sure if you have
any queries that you're
running or any interesting
notes that you have saved inside
of your Google Cloud
Platform Qwiklabs account,
that you copy and paste those
and save them somewhere else,
perhaps in your own personal
Google Cloud Platform
account or somewhere
locally on your machine.
And once you've clicked
End Lab, then you
can enter feedback for the lab.
And you can continue moving on.
So again, a quick recap.
One of the key
things to remember
is in order to get
those credentials here
on the left hand side, you
have to click Start Lab, which,
again, kicks off the timer.
And there's no way to pause
once the lab is started,
but again, keep in mind,
you have multiple attempts.
And lastly, click
on End Lab when
you're ready to completely
complete out the lab
that you've been working on.
That's it.
Good luck with the
lab, and enjoy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: What
are the next steps?
Here are the next
steps to get started
with the Associate
Cloud Engineer track.
First, log in as
a Coursera Admin.
You should have received
a link via email.
Next, create a CSV file
with the names and email
addresses of students, and
enroll them in the program.
Conduct Study Jam 1 for the
students who have enrolled.
Study Jam 1 is a workshop aimed
to introduce your students
to the program and
learning platforms.
Review Faculty FAQ if
you have any questions.
Here is a checklist
that you can use
to keep track of all
the activities you'll
need to complete.
The checklist can be accessed
from the faculty FAQ page.
To summarize, your
goals are as follows.
As a learner within the
Associate Cloud Engineer track
timeline, complete the
architecting with GCP
specialization on Coursera.
Finish extra practice
with Qwiklabs.
Use the available 100%
discount for faculty
on the Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification Exam.
As a coach for your students
within the Associate Cloud
Engineer track timeline,
conduct three study jams
for the Associate
Cloud engineer track.
Ensure that all
students complete
the architecting with GCP
specialization on Coursera
within the timeline prescribed
in the Coursera program
invitation.
Ensure that all students
prepare for the Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification Exam,
and use the available discount.
With the Google Cloud
Associate Cloud engineer track,
help your students reach
high, and lead them
to a cloud-first world.